so if you haven't heard there's a crisis
in America a student loan crisis over 1
trillion dollars in student loan debt
some people say it's because colleges
charge too much some people say it's
because we have irresponsible borrowers
some people say it's because Congress
put in place a plan that should have
never been there in the first place
I could raise my hand at probably all
three of those and just say yep but
really all of that doesn't matter to you
but why it's the way it is doesn't
matter to you you have to decide to make
good choices in the midst of the
environment that you live in and let me
help you with this the president is
going to announce two years of a free
college that is not going to get through
a Republican Congress he knows it's not
going to so it's a complete political
move don't sit around and wait on the
federal government to pay for your
college it's not gonna happen okay we
got that out of the way it's a bunch of
political crap in other words he's just
positioning to make their try to make
they're probably gonna look bad for the
Fall run for his party that's all that
is so don't sit around wait on free
Community College it's not coming unless
your state is already doing it but the
feds are not going to pull that off it's
not gonna pass so just give you a
hundred percent on that so here's the
peers the thing it's up to you you get
to send you to college what a novel idea
so Rachael Cruz joins me my daughter and
co-author of the book smart money smart
kids where we devote an entire chapter
to talking about how to go to college
and you know the that would you know
just how to go to college and not going
to debt so how are we gonna do that
that's the plan so it's that time of
year isn't it it is yes thanks for
having me back on but the acceptance
letters are rolling in for a lot of high
school seniors here in the in the spring
semester for them to choose a school in
the fall so we figured that this would
be a good time to give you listeners
some some words of advice if you're a
parent or if you're a student listening
that'd be really pretty great if you
were a high school senior
the Dave Ramsey show but free parents
out there to just give you tools and
applications that instill in your kids
so that they make wise choices because
they're 18 and you can't forget that
then you got kids juniors in high school
moment I've taken them on college tours
right now and trying to consider where
they're going to go after their senior
year it's kind of that season yes
seniors getting ready to graduate in the
spring and head off to college so it's
that season there's a lot of college
selection going on at this particular
moment a lot of discussion about where
to go to college and really where to go
to college is part of the equation but
you know there's a big discussion in
society today with the student loan
crisis I think that's what's brought it
up is is college worth it is it worth it
to spend the money on college what do
you think you're out there bumping
around talking to people every day oh
gosh okay well I would say as you're
applying for jobs and you're going into
a career it does make you more
marketable to have a four-year degree I
think you know or even a two-year degree
to have an advanced degree I think that
that it does your your head does kind of
peak above the rest of the crowd I would
say but it doesn't guarantee a job and I
would say though people focus more on
what's on the Diploma the school name
versus what they're studying and what
they're doing to mean employers you mean
the people go into school sometimes are
too worried about schools yeah yeah
that's what I mean yeah okay so I think
that our our mindset is has shifted to
more the importance of where you're
going to school versus just the idea of
hey just getting a just a good college
education even if it's a community
college even if it's a state school
going back to the basics of that so but
but college isn't for everyone so I
would say that as well well I think
there's two things that you get an ROI
on a return on investment with college
the obvious one is is that you put tools
in your belt that enable you to do a job
you can't be an accountant without an
accounting degree you have to learn
accounting if you learn marketing you
know you can do marketing without a
marketing degree but if you learn more
about
marketing you're gonna be more effective
at marketing that's putting tools in
your belt and so whether you're running
your own business which I do or whether
you're working with someone on someone's
team either one of those situations you
know you're putting tools in your belt
and there is an ROI now that presupposes
that you're getting a degree that
actually matters and that's why I always
make fun and evidence I don't get a
degree in German polka history you know
because there's no market for that so
there's the actual ROI of you will make
more because you're worth more because
you have more tools in your belt you
know things that other people don't know
that make you bring value to that
organization caused them to make more
money because you're there than if you
weren't educated and but that you know
that that again assumes you're actually
studying something that the marketplace
cares about and so you you know and you
have to think about that there's nothing
wrong with getting an art degree but you
need to understand that the marketplace
is a very thin appreciation a very
narrow appreciation for your art degree
in terms of them paying you for that you
get a degree in theater you're gonna get
the same thing it's a very narrow
application of that versus getting a
degree say in a general business
situation or getting a degree Richards
got degree in communications that's a
broader degree that has more places of
application light-years more places of
application than some of these other
degrees well that's hard as is talking
to these college students who are not
only getting a useless degree in my
opinion but going into debt for it or
getting them even of even a higher
education Astor's degree well it was two
dumb decisions well talking you know I
just talked to a girl uh-huh
it was gosh probably three or four
months ago and she has him her master's
degree in women's studies and she's a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
debt mm-hmm she's like I don't know what
I want to do with women's studies yes
how did you not think through this
degree that you're getting yourself into
so so yeah I think through what you're
studying when you're going to school
yeah there's not a lot of grants for the
study of women I mean seriously you you
just have to think through and use your
brain on that and people don't they
because they've been told this lie that
if I just get a degree
I'm guaranteed to win rights and if I
get a master's degree I'm double
guaranteed to win right and that's just
not true so in that sense education is
not worth it it is worth it and you'll
get a substantial ROI if you get a
degree that's applicable in the
marketplace in other words a utilitarian
look at education are you gonna utilize
it then yes it's worth it and I would
say yes go get a four-year degree in
business if you're gonna go into
business your brother's got one of those
your sister has a degree in Child and
Family Studies and is in in ministry so
it's perfectly a broad degree and yours
is in communication you use that every
day and some of the training and the
things you've got there
so yes I think it's worth it I think
there's an ROI on it the second way you
get a return on investment of getting a
degree is a person that has an education
knows more than someone that doesn't
hello and so you're are able to increase
your enjoyment in your life because you
have an appreciation for things if
you've taken a language you you can
function a little bit with someone with
a different language if you've taken an
art class you have an appreciation of
art that someone else didn't have a
music class and so on and so it just
broadens your the the depth and the
quality of your life now that argument
is used for a lot of people going tens
of thousands of dollars in student loan
debt and I will tell you that that part
while it is is fair and is real is not
worth any money and so what that would
be is a luxury the other would be more
on the necessity side and so if you want
to go get a degree just to get a degree
just to say I'm educated just because I
want to learn about this that's a luxury
and that certainly falls under the
heading of paying cash all of this falls
on the heading of paying cash but that
one does and just know that that degree
is gonna get you nothing if you study in
one of those areas except just to
broaden your horizons in general but
does it are you gonna get money back in
your pocket because you got a degree in
one of those areas no you're not you're
not so is college worth it yes if you
select the College carefully so you
don't overpay
and if you study a field of study that
is applicable in the marketplace then
it's definitely worth it I believe that
thus I paid for three of my children my
three children all three of them to go
to college and pretty much brainwashed
them their whole freakin life they were
going to be doing it but we also talked
a lot about college selection and career
are our field of study choice and I had
input into that because I was freaking
paying for it so we're gonna talk more
about this and how to go to college
debt-free after this break Rachel Cruz
is my guest